and
part of protecting yourself
means protect yourself from the
misinformation and of course the
staggeringly stupid advice
coming from the right
paul gosar has become one of the latest
people on the right
to actively encourage people
to fight back against
covet protections
in a video that surfaced this week put
out there by ethan schmidt who runs the
so-called anti-masters club
so you know right off the bat with the
name there you can tell super serious
organization
got a video of gosar
and gosar said this hey here's to that
anti-vaxxer group stay the course
and then schmidt replies yeah
anti-vaxxer club
stay the course he's telling the
anti-vaxxers
the people who are actively telling the
rest of the country to not get the
vaccine
stay the course
omicron is 73 percent of new cases
across the country that graph is once
again making another swing
this is what the fifth sixth wave
of covid we are now experiencing
in this yahoo
who serves in congress
has a medical degree
is telling people
listen to the anti-vaxxers don't give up
your anti-vaxx ways i mean that's what
stay the course means
it means keep doing what you're doing
keep spreading misinformation paul
is that what you want them to be doing
because the statistics also show that
not only is coveted rising but
it's rising faster in areas that voted
for donald trump which means it's rising
faster among republicans
we also know that
far more republicans are unvaccinated
than democrats
to put it another way you're killing
your base
as i mentioned earlier on this week's
program being a republican is basically
a comorbidity with covet at this point
and their own lawmakers members of their
own party are actively telling them
keep it keep it up keep doing it
you're you're killing them
you're actively killing them
much like sarah palin suggested
at the turning point usa conference you
know oh you keep fighting back we don't
need the shot i'll get the shot over my
dead body
sarah palin says
encouraging others to not do the bare
minimum
to protect themselves
and at some point
if people like gosar and palin of course
continue saying these things we're going
to have to have a real conversation
ahead of the midterms
about what the mortality rate of covid
has done to the american electorate
and i know that's a rather morbid
conversation that a lot of people are
avoiding but but that's something we do
have to talk about
because again for months now this has
been primarily a republican
centric
disease
only about 10 percent of democrats
self-identified democrats say they're
not vaccinated
almost 40 percent of republicans say
they're not
and
we're almost seeing the same kind of
ratio
in the death totals for covid
they're actively killing their base
they're giving them this horrendous
advice
that is killing them
so how is that going to play out in the
midterms it is going to have an impact
so again
that's a tough conversation it's
certainly an unpleasant conversation
but it's one that we're going to have to
have in the coming year and maybe we
need to have the conversation sooner
look i'm obviously on the left right i
have my politics on the left
but that doesn't mean that i want to see
anyone
on the right
die from this virus i don't want to see
any human being die from this virus
again
if i could stop it right now if we had a
magic wand i would do it i wasn't i
wouldn't hesitate even you know
we have to put the politics aside but
in order to do that
we have to be able to convince
the people on the other side
that they have to care about this that
they have to take care of themselves
so maybe it is time to have those
conversations about republicans killing
off their base and what that's going to
do to their election chances because i
guarantee you
if they look at those voting rolls
and see that they've lost enough voters
that could have swung an election in
previous years
they're going to change their tune
they're suddenly going to realize oh
wait a minute you know what maybe mass
are good
maybe
maybe people ought to get vaccinated
so it is time for those conversations if
for no other reason
than to scare republican politicians
into finally doing the right thing
and encouraging their base to protect
themselves
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below